a quien quiero y la guerra está presente
en cada una de sus calles con mensajes
patrióticos
canciones reservistas paseando o
simplemente haciendo cola en las
oficinas es verdad que esta ciudad la
capital está poco a poco intentando
volver al menos a reactivar su actividad
económica o parte de ella hay pequeños
empresarios que abren sus negocios en
los restaurantes los hoteles eso sí
siempre con precaución porque los
misiles siguen sobrevolando esta región
y siguen impactando también en la región
de kiev incluso hay familias que se
aventuran para poder desconectar de todo
lo que está ocurriendo y para paliar la
ola de calor que también se está
viviendo aquí en ucrania acuden a ríos y
lagos pero siempre con ese miedo de lo
que pueda ocurrir por los bombardeos
esta situación contrasta mucho con lo
que está ocurriendo en el donbass en cbd
ones ilicic antes es ahí donde se está
dando la mayor intensidad de los
combates en estos momentos en la guerra
de ucrania